after 24 years as a late-night host I've
pretty much had the opportunity to work
with just about every megastar in the
business every megastar except one
probably the biggest star of them all
I'm talking about Tom Cruise okay we
have a there he is there's a photo of
him and Kate there it's let's see some
photos of Tom Cruise just to refresh
everyone's memory that I'm talking about
Tom Cruise what a stupid waste of time
to show photos of Tom Cruise Tom Cruise
let's show you some photos yeah yeah
just in case you've never heard of Tom
Cruise anyway I've always wanted to do
something with Tom but it never quite
worked out
so last week I flew to London found out
where tom was staying forced my way in I
found a flaw in their security and I
pitched him an idea now I'll be honest
it's an unconventional idea but I'm a
risk taker okay now after hearing my
kind of strange idea Tom agreed to give
it a shot so we taped it several days
ago now I think it turned out great I
really do Tom may or may not agree
neither he nor his publicists are
responding to my phone calls I don't
know what that means he's probably just
busy he's got a new movie out American
made he's probably focusing on that
right it takes a lot of time to email a
guy go right yeah
all I asked is that you tune in to my
show tomorrow night to see two of the
world's biggest stars but both at the
I'm one of them both at the top of their
game try something that has never been
done before I don't think that's a lot
to ask and Tom if you're watching please
call me back it's Conan Conan O'Brien
from that thing we did just a couple
days
you